another reading is of a new york times  article that describes the use case for  crypto and bitcoin in particular in  venezuela the country's in crisis  hyperinflation is throughout the economy  the value of traditional currency has  basically dropped to zero in that kind  of a situation  crypto has real value it allows people  to engage in basic transactions it  allows them to obtain food it allows  them to obtain medicine  it lets value come into the economy and  lets value leave the economy  the value of crypto in failed states or  in situations involving runaway  inflation is i think entirely clear  when you can't trust the law perhaps  we're best off being able to trust the  code